[موسيقى]
لوحة هاون يمكنهم القيام بها إما أن تكون
هذه الإبل
هي الأخيرة من نوعها ، وكانت هذه
الإبل جزءًا مهمًا من
ثقافة هذا المجتمع
لآلاف السنين.  منهج أحمد
محمد مبارك جاما هاري داس ليتراس
يجعل من إريك هيميل
مدرستها البيئية في بلغاريا
ستنزل في جانو أو مجتمع محمد ،
هناك 150 من الإبل السابحة التي
تعتني بالإبل كانت جزءًا من عمل هذه
العائلة لأجيالنا
المتعددة هل نيكا تأتي يا بيلا
سينيورينا  لكل دولار في الثانية
chimeritope الحالي Dada be Kurata forum
errababu Kurata هل يمكننا التغلب على
[موسيقى]
هذا النوع الفريد من الإبل
موطن المنطقة وقد تطور بمرور الوقت
للبقاء على قيد الحياة في هذه البيئة شديدة
اللحن اللحن البارد Karaka
Montana Hotel quesadilla
عقلية معلمي أو WAP هي قنبلة
فصل عنصري ، يا عزيزي كاثي كوي ،
تتراكم البازيليكا في ableton للحفاظ على المسار
لقد أدت مشكلة إيذاء الجمال إلى
تحدياتها ، حيث بدأت الصناعات الجديدة
تزاحم المنطقة وتغير المناخ
يضر بموائلها للحفاظ على
نمط حياتهم مثل نوير محمد
وعائلته وقد بدأوا في بيع
حليب الإبل
[موسيقى]
da-da-da-da-da-  da-da helical DT كوسوفو
ستأتي ملكة مصرفي الخوران فيتا نوفا
سكارا إلى كاراباخ - عزيزتي يمكن أن تكون
سوق غريغورا بفضل هذا
العمل الجديد والشراكة القديمة
، ستستمر الرابطة بين الإنسان والجمال السابحة
لأجيال قادمة
وكبار السن  طرق لا شيء منسي
بناء كان واضحا جدا من هذا
[موسيقى]